this was the scene that confronted
rescuers these carriages were packed
with passengers many of whom are injured
it's understood some of the people on
board were children heading home from
school for the half-term holidays
a serious train crash occurred here a
regional train which departed from the
town of garmisch park and kirchen
heading to munich derailed shortly after
leaving the station for reasons unknown
several train carriages tipped over and
fell down an embankment
it took emergency services several hours
to extract everyone from the wreckage
some were so badly hurt they needed to
be airlifted to hospital for treatment
it's likely many on board would have
been using the new 10 monthly ticket
which allows unlimited regional travel
this stretch of line links a ski resort
with the bavarian capital munich the
derailment happened on a bend close to
the main road in the river loisach
no other vehicle was involved in the
incident and the weather conditions at
the time were good
an investigation is underway to piece
together the final moments of the
journey and find out what caused the
train to leave the tracks
dominic kane al jazeera berlin